a closer look at the injuries wood
suffered in the crash and his chances
for recovery
we bring in cbs news medical contributor
dr david agus david good morning
tiger's doctors describe his injuries as
fractures affecting both the upper and
lower portions of the tibia and fibula
bones
they they say they inserted a rod into
the tibia
and his foot and ankles ankle were
stabilized with screws
and pins what exactly does that mean for
him
well you know obviously this was serious
trauma he got taken to a level one
trauma center ucla
uh harbor hospital which is an excellent
hospital
and we're very lucky and he's very lucky
over that you know i have this little
uh a man here and what you can see is
this front bone is the tibia
so tibia is the large bone you could
feel in front of your leg
and there are two fractures in it where
they had to put a rod in
with pins on either side to stabilize
this bone and then here in the ankle
we're also multiple bones fractured
where they put screws in
and they're able to keep it stabilized
for healing
the healing process here takes four to
six months but luckily
it's done the surgery now so so
you're talking about a four to six month
recovery for these injuries specifically
we don't know like he mentioned in in
carter's story
uh that he has problems with his back do
you think they'll likely be affected by
this as well
no no question i mean it's not just the
bones it's the muscles they mentioned in
the press
uh conference also that the muscles
around the legs
were traumatized and so that caused
swelling and they actually had to put a
slit in each of the muscles
to allow the pressure to be relieved so
it's going to take a while to retrain
these muscles to enable these bones to
heal
over the rod and to enable him to walk
again
so how long do you think that process
could take david
you know i mean it's only guessing i
mean obviously i don't know all of the
details but we're talking at least six
months of recovery here
um you know to be able to get to some
semblance of walking um
to playing a sport to playing golf i
just don't know enough
yeah all right dr david agus thank you
very much